من بعد غياب عن الموسم الرمضاني السابق
بتعود النجمه غاده عبد الرازق لتخوض
السباق الرمضاني بقوه ضمن مسلسل ثلث
الثلاثه وهو من الاعمال اللي انطلقت من
نصف الشهر وفي المسلسل غاده عبد الرازق
طالعه في واحد تلعب دور ثلاث شخصيات فريده
فريال وفرح وهم ثلاث اخوات توام كل وحده
فيهم بتعمل في مهنه مختلفه وبتصير معاهم
احداث مثيره ومن اول الحلقات بدات تشويق
على طول فريده اكتشفت خيانه زوجها اللي
بعدها دبر لها مكيده عشان يتخلص منها لكن
كانت الضحيه اختها فريال بدات الاحداث
اتنين مفلسين التالين قتله خلصوا على بعض
[موسيقى]
ولا
نعقل كده ونكمل بقيه اتفقنا
[تصفيق]
الميتين لا يمكن يصح
[موسيقى]
عشان ممكن ينتبه السكينه دي ما بتقطعش
اللحمه كويس انا مش ضعيفه زيك
وعمري ما سبت راجل يتحكم في حياتي ومع انه
المسلسل انطلق من كم يوم بس لكن الاصداء
حقيقه بادئه وبقوه وردود الافعال بتشيل في
المسلسل واللي جلسه بتقدمه او بيقدموا
غاده عبد الرازق فيه ثلاث شخصيات
هو معنى من القاهره النجمه غاده عبد
الرازق اهلا فيكي معانا يا غاده وكل عام
وانت بالف خير ومنوره في رمضان
وانت بالصحه والسلامه يا رب حبيبتي
المشهد اللي احنا عرضناه الان اخر شيء
يعني صار ترند على السوشيال ميديا والناس
صارت كلها تبعته يعني طبعا هي فكره يعني
جهنميه جهنميه جهنميه انا حابه اعرف منك
انت يا غاده ايش احسن حل للتعامل مع
الخاين
بصي والله انا يعني مش هرد الرد اللي انا
بقول ان هم يعني يتعمل فيه كده احنا شويه
بنعمل حاجات طبعا عشان تعجب الناس عشان اه
دراما لكن عموما عموما اي بني ادم خاين او
كذاب
شيء طبيعي طبعا ان انت
تبعدي عنه تماما تشيلي من حياتك
ما تحاولوش تقولي فرصه اولى وفرصه تانيه
لان
كثره الفرص دي بتخليك انت بعد كده تطلعي
مبررات
للخاين عشان تتعايشى معاه
ده في حد ذاته انا بقول ان ده خطر خطر جدا
ممتاز هذه حكمه اولى لكل النساء من الذي
بدانا بحكمه في موضوع الخيانه خلينا نرجع
للمسلسل المسلسل يعني ايش اللي يشهدك فيه
وخلاك تقولي انا ابغى ارجع هذا لرمضان
بهذا العمل
المكتوب حلو قوي انه طرد شخصيات وانا
اتعرض عليا كتير زمان اني اعمل فكره
التوائم بس كان دايما اتنين مش عارفه ايه
حاجات كده فكنت بشوفها مستهلكه قوي وما
فيهاش جديده اقدمه للناس اول مره احس ان
التلاته
شبه بعض يعني انا كنت متمسكه جدا اني ما
اعملش فرق في الشكل فيهم تماما يوم واحده
بقى شعرها اصفر واحده احمر وواحده
لاني شفت توائم كتير تلاتات بنات واولاد
نسخه من بعضهم يعني درجه ان هم هم بيكلموا
بيكلموا زي بعض
فحبيت الفكره دي قوي وحبيت الساسبينس
والحاجه النفسيه لان انا بحس ان دي
المنطقه اللي انا بتميز بها او يعني
نجحت نجحتي فيها بقوه
الحمد لله قبل كده طبعا كمان ثلاث حاجه
ودي الاهم اني
رجعت حد نفسي عشان تعملي تلات شخصيات
التلاته شبه بعض خارجيا لكن داخليا
مختلفين تماما عن بعض
فكريا
حتى حتى اكلهم يعني في واحده فيهم
فيجيتريان في واحده مش عارفه ايه دي كانت
تحدي بالنسبه للغاده عبد الرازق اني العب
تلات شخصيات في وقت واحد واللي اصعب كمان
ان الناس ما تعرفش ان انا بقف قصاد نفسي
بمثل وما فيش حد قدامي ايوه انا حابه
تشرحي هادي الجزئيه يا غاده لانه كتير ناس
ما يعرفوها انت بتمثلي مشاهد مع نفسك انت
قدام نفسك اشرحي لنا بتعمليها
هقول لك يعني مثلا هيبقى مثلا زي في مشهد
مثلا التلاته مع بعض فمثلا اتنين قاعدين
وواحده واقفه بلبس الاول فريده واخش على
الكرسي
واكلم فرح هنا واكلم فريال هنا بس هو مفيش
حد هو في هواء وبعدين ارجع البس فرح اقعد
الناحيه التانيه واكلم في ريال كده واكلم
فريده كده وبرضو هوا مفيش حد وبعدين البس
فريال اللي هي الثالثه
واطلع اتكلم مع فريده وفرح بس انا بكلمك
الاثنين كرسي فاضيين يعني ولكن انت خالي
بقى معايا 180 شخص
العاملين معايا
فانا ببقى واقفه قدامهم كاني زي المجنونه
بكلم نفسي بكلم الهوا يعني انت بتوجهي
كلام من هنا بعدين ترجعي وتغيري شخصيتك
وشكلك وكل شيء وتتكلمي مره يعني الموضوع
فعلا مو سهل لما تقولي تحدي جدا
ومطلوب كمان مني بقى ان انا وانا بمثل
مثلا تتخانق مثلا مع اخت من الاخوات
ابقى انا جوايا بمثل هي هي هترد علي ازاي
اللي هي انا يعني انا هرد على نفسي انا
ازاي في الخناقه دي جننتينا يا غاده ههه
فانا متخيله انا جنني
فريق العمل طيب بس كمان المره هذه يمكن
كمان اللي مختلف انه 15 حلقه وبادئين من
النص رمضان ليش هذه الخطوه
هقول لك ليه لان العمل ده كان مكتوب من
سنه ونص او سنتين وكان 30 حلقه وكنا هنخش
نصور حصل لنا مشكله
قعدنا حوالي 65 يوم خلاص خدنا قرار ان
احنا مش هنخش المسلسل ده السنه دي السنه
الجايه فحصل برضو
مناوشات كده وجينا قعدنا مع بعض
وكان في يعني اصرار فقلت لهم لو في اصرار
قوي هيبقى 15 مش هقدر اجازب ب 30 لان
العمل دوت عايز شغله عايز تركيز قوي
وعايزني انا كممثله ابقى حاضره ذهنيا
ونفسيا عشان اعرف ارجع تاني يعني عشان
اعمل اللي انا عايزاه اوكي لما وصلت لده
وضمنته الحمد لله رب العالمين
دخلت صورت
طيب وبصور لحد دلوقتي ايوه انا عارفه انت
طالعه من اللوكيشن هذا القصر اللي انت
ساكنه فيه المفروض في المسلسل يعني
متابعين معاكي متابعين معاكي لاحداث
بتتحرك جلسه بسرعه واحنا جالسين بنتابع
معاك الموضوع طيب بس كمان يعني خلي بالك
على فكره انا مو منت انا من متابعين قناه
العربيه يوميا يا حبيبه قلبي يا سلام
هذا الكلام المعروفه عني
بس والله ده حقيقه انا مش بجامل لان انا
اول حاجه باصحى الصبح وانا بفطر لازم اسمع
الاخبار ايوه حتى بالليل لما باجي انام هو
بيجيهم مثلا قنوات تانيه اول ما انزل
الصبح وافتح التلفزيون اه
مقفول عليها من بالليل
لا برافو يا غاده تستاهلي عشر نجمات على
هذا الموضوع ممتاز وكمان ركزي على تفاعل
والله العظيم ركزي على تفاعلكم وعلى ساره
بس دي فعلا والله حقيقه من عيني حاضر طيب
خليني كمان اقول لك يمكن واحده من الاشياء
اللي كمان قالوا انه سببت يعني كده دوشه
عندكم كان انه تغيير المخرج انه صار في
اعتذار من المخرج الاساسي هو ايش صار صار
في مشاكل صار يعني ايش اللي صار
لا مش مشاكل هو خاف الاستاذ هشام المخرج
الاولاني خاف جدا لما الدقيق الوقت
اتقلل وانه 15 حلقه فهو
يعني اتخض يعني لا ازاي انا مش هلحق انا
مش هلحق من كل اللي انا عايزه مش هلحق
اعمل واعمل واعمل واعمل واعمل وانا صراحه
كنت خلاص اديت كلمه ان شاء الله داخله
وخلاص بقى في فرقابتي ناس
عملوا حسابهم وبيشتغلوا دلوقتي وان فلوسهم
ان شاء الله هتيجي فما كنتش اقدر
يعني اقول له قلت له خلاص هركب طبعا ده
شيء طبيعي انا محتاجه في حضرتك لكن انا
مضطريه بعد اذنك طبعا اجيب مخرج ثاني قال
لي اه طبعا انا اتمنى لكم كل الخير وده
اللي عملناه الحمد لله ربنا كرمنا برضو
كلنا مع بعض الحمد لله
شيء فهو خير لكم صحيح انه يعني بالضبط ما
تعرفي وين الخير فيلم المواضيع عادي بس
كمان كان في اختيار ليله زاهر عشان تشاركك
العمل وطبعا يعني دائما في حديث كان عن
خلافك مع والدها الفنان الكبير احمد زاهر
وقالوا انه الاختيار ليله كان مفاجاه
للجميع وبعدين يعني انا شخصيا يعني وانا
بتكلم مع الفنان احمد زاهر وزوجته هدى
كانوا بيتكلموا كمان قديش انك انت كنت
رائعه في التعامل معها وقديش انك انت
احتضنتيها فعليا هذا الاختيار كيف جاء
اولا ليلى كنت انا مختاراها من قبل ما
احمد يطلع في البرنامج ويقول ان في مشاكل
حتى انا نفسي
استغربت قوي انا واحمد عمران متخانقنا عمر
ما كان في بينا خناقه حتى قصاد بعض كده
وزعقنا مع بعض فانا قلت اكيد اكيد حد وصل
له او حد قال له ده فبالتالي هو خد الخطوه
من غير ما يسالني فاهمه
بس
فلم ده حصل في الجمله قالوا لي طيب انت
شايفه ايه يعني ليلى قلتله لا لا لا ليلى
هتيجي وليلى هتشتغل وبعدين دي مهنه احنا
بروفيشنال يا جماعه احنا مش مش ممثلين
ابدا اللي بصفي حسابات شخصيه في شغلتي
مهنتي دي اكل عيشي دي دي حاجه
كنت بحلم بيها طول حياتي هي اللي عملتني
فهل هنا ابقى ست ادخل في شغلي اصل مين
قالوا فلان عادو لا لا لا وبالذات ان بجد
بجد
انا ما بكرهوش انا مش عارفه هو جايب
الكلام ده منين الحاجه الوحيده بس اللي
قلتها له قلت له احمد قبل ما تقول اتاكد
لان ممكن انا انا حكايتي عدت انا ست ذكيه
وخبرتي بسني ممكن ده يحصل مع حد تاني ما
يبقاش عنده خبرتي او ما يبقاش زيي فهماني
فتحصل بجد مشكله هو بس عشان يعني التوضيح
هو جاي الوقت انه تم استبعاده من عمل
بسببك يعني
فانت بتقولي انه لا هذا الشيء ما صار حتى
اوكي طيب
خليني كمان يصير يمكن انقلك على موضوع
التسارع الاحداث يعني نحن عدينا الان يعني
في اربع حلقات وكل حلقه مليانه مليانه
مليانه يعني يعني انتم متعمدين تعملوا هذا
الشيء انه الحلقه يكون رتمها مليان
اه اكيد بس اقول لك حاجه هو اللي خدمنا ان
احنا اصلا بقول لك كنا كاتبين مسلسل من
سنتين اوكي وكانوا 30 حلقه انا
مشدودين فلما اختصرت الثلاثين اللي انت
واخده فيهم مجهود جامد قوي وعملتيهم في 15
ما بقاش عندك نفس خلاص خلاص
حابه بس اسالك اسئله سريعه في المواقع
اللي هي بتصنف المسلسلات حاطين ان المسلسل
للكبار فقط بتتفقي مع هذا التصنيف
لكبار فقط
مش عارفه حاطينه كده يمكن علشان مشهد انه
انه في خيانه وكذا
على الشاشه صاير
بده بيفتحوا الحاجات دي على النت كله
بينعرض على الشاشه كده طيب خليني بدي
اسالك كمان شوي تاني انت قبل صرحتي كمان
انك انت في ايام التصوير الطويله ما
بتصومي وتصريحك ده اكيد شفتي الجدل اللي
عمله اصلا بشكل عام غاده انت اي تصريح لك
بتعملي على طول جدل وترد والكلام ده كله
فانت لما قلت انا ايام التصوير الطويله
جدل على هذا الموضوع بتحبي توضحي شيء عن
هذا الكلام
اوضح انا ما قلتش كده على فكره انا قلت
ساعات لو طبقت في التصوير في التصوير
يومين او تلاته ورا بعض
ما اقدرش اصوم فيهم لاني باخد ادويه ادويه
سابوا كل اللي انا قلته ده ايوه
اصلها ما بتصومش في رمضان لما بتشتغل
ممتاز غاده انك انت الان وضحتي هذا
الموضوع لانه العناوين فعلا كلها اجتزقت
جزء معين يعني فجيد انك انت وضحتي هذا
الشيء غدا انا عارفه انك انت بتصوري وانك
حابه تقولي تضيفي شيء تفضلي
عايزه اقول كل سنه وانتم طيبين
ورمضان كريم وعيد سعيد وبحبكم جدا احنا
اللي بنحبك اكثر بس انا كمان العربي بكل
ناس انا حابه بس كمان غاده طبعا احنا
هنستمر في الحديث عن المسلسل وواضح انه
اصلا الايام الجايه الحديث مستمر على
المسلسل هيكون لانه كل يوم فعلا بيكون
ترند يعني
بس معانا ان شاء الله كمان مؤلفه المسلسل
وهي حترد على بعض الجدل اللي صاير على هذه
القصه والدعاوى اللي طالعه على المسلسل
ذلك واحنا هنسالها عن هذا الموضوع بس كنت
حابه اشوف اذا انت حضرتك عندك تعليق او
تحبي تضيفي شيء على هذا الموضوع
هقول حاجه واحده بس دايما الشجر المثمره
بيحدفوها بالطوب انا فاكره كويس جدا ان كل
الاعمال اللي انا عملتها اللي كانت ناجحه
وعملت بوم من اول اسبوع اتقال عليها نفس
الكلام
وهفكرك ونفس الكلام ده حصل في سبق الاصرار
وحكايه حياه والكابوس وحدوته مره نفس ده
بالظبط بالملي
دايما يعني ما شاء الله عليك يعني النجاح
كمان بيجي معه ما نقدر ننكر الشي والسؤال
الاخير يا غاده كيف ما شاء الله بتفضلي
حلوه
عشان نفسيتي كويسه
حلو الجواب ده كلنا بنقول طب والله لو انا
يعني نفسيتي انا نفسي تكون كويسه كمان يا
غاده على كده حاحاول اخلي نفسيتي كويسه
دلوقتي انت حلوه ههه خلاص اسمع يا غاده
انت احسن مسلسل في رمضان وانت عشره نجمات
كل شيء انت خلاص انا انت نجمتين 10 على 10
انت الان خلاص
حبيبتي بالتوفيق وانا بقول للناس الصراحه
يشوفوا المسلسل لانه فعلا احداث متسارعه
ومختلف عن كل اللي موجود حقيقه يعني الحمد
لله
نورتينا يا غاده نورتينا نورتينا وانا
عارفه من التصوير ارجع للتصوير وكميه
تصويرك وبالتوفيق دائما وابدا حبيبتي شكرا
لك
[موسيقى]